hey 42 here men wanted for hazardous
journey low wages bitter cold long hours
of complete darkness safe return
doubtful honor and recognition an event
of success that was the advertisement
which Ernest Shackleton ran in London
newspapers in 1901 seeking to recruit
Hardy men for a perilous journey would
you apply for this job over 5,000 men
and free women did after interviewing
all hopefuls Shackleton sorted the
applicants into free baskets mad
hopeless and possible but Shackleton
wasn't gathering a crew for his now
renowned expedition endurance that will
come later
Shackleton's first voyage as a captain
nimrod set sail from Littleton Harbor
New Zealand on the 1st of January 1908
the expedition aimed to reach the
geographic South Pole respectively it
was a failure in its primary objective
but a success in that Shackleton and his
crew set a new record for the farthest
southern latitude reached by any human
thus far the truly great testament to
Shackleton that we can take from the
Nimrod expedition was his ability to
uphold morale even when the crews
outlook seemed as bleak as the icy
tundra eternally ahead of them
Shackleton's natural charm and ability
to communicate on a deep level with his
men kept their spirits tremendously high
during their return journey to McMurdo
Sound starvation was their greatest foe
supplies were dwindling Shackleton
allotted one biscuit per day to each of
the crew upon seeing that his comrade
Frank Wilde was on the precipice of
death Shackleton gave up his own daily
biscuit to Frank all the money in the
world that was ever minted would not
have bought that biscuit and the
remembrance of that sacrifice
we'll never leave me Frank noted in his
diary
Shackleton's diary during his flirtation
with fatality simply read difficulties
are just things to overcome after all
a few years later Shackleton's resolute
resourceful persona would prove
fundamental in achieving one of the
greatest stories of survival that
history has ever known
despite his failure Shackleton's efforts
didn't go unrewarded back at home by the
public or the monarchy king george v
knighted him he was in the eyes of the
people a national hero yet he was
destitute Shackleton underwent a period
of unrest and financial difficulty
attempting various economic ventures to
try to make ends meet the Nimrod
expedition had left him and his family
in serious debt a tobacco company
stamped salesmen to collectors and an
investor in Hungarian mining operations
all such avenues Shackleton pursued yet
non paid any dividend all the while the
growing concern that a rival South Pole
pursuant namely Amundsen or Scott's
could claim the title of first pressed
upon Shackleton's mine with a crushing
force of a Titanic iceberg on the 14th
of December 1911
Shackleton's worst fear unfolded Norway
had beaten the British and Roald
Amundsen had picked Shackleton to the
post at the bottom of the world
Shackleton was a frustrated man but she
prevent his legacy from decaying with
time and being overshadowed by Amazon's
victory
he had to hastily form a new plan to
earn his desired scientific and
historical recognition Shackleton would
regularly confide in his comrades with
his wishes to return to the icy
continents despite hiding such ambitions
from his wife these wishes manifested in
a novel plan the Imperial Transantarctic
expedition designed to be the first
expedition in human history to traverse
the Antarctic continent from ocean to
ocean due to the unstoppable March of
war dawning upon the horizon securing
funding for Shackleton's new expedition
would prove near impossible the Royal
Geographic Society despite the
expedition's potential to hunk of a new
scientific knowledge from Antarctica was
not amused but one of Shackleton's
greatest attributes was his unremitting
charm eventually he did secure funding
in the form of 10,000 pounds from a
government grant another 10,000 pounds
from wealthy industrialist Dudley docker
an undisclosed sum from the daughter of
a tobacco heiress Janet stank home wills
and the most substantial so from wealthy
jute
tycoon a plant used to make rope James
Caird
of Dundee to the tune of 24,000 pounds
this final bout of funding was not
secured until the very eve of World War
one Shackleton's crew could not depart
on to Winston Churchill himself First
Lord of the Admiralty granted permission
for Shackleton's expedition to continue
by sending Shackleton one-word telegram
proceed
rather than leveraging the crews
profound collective naval abilities to
aid the war efforts as Shackleton
expected to happen
the expedition was able to set sail on
the 8th of August 1914 five days after
the outbreak of war the vessel for this
most ambitious expedition would be most
ironically Norwegian built Polaris
Shackleton of course renamed it to
endurance inspired by his family motto
by endurance we conquer weighing a
hearty 315 tonnes constructed from oak
Norwegian fur and green hearts it was
designed for one end and that was as its
namesake supposed to enjoy it is perhaps
the greatest irony of all Victorian era
exploration that the renowned endurance
did not enjoy
but the real the true and Joran's was to
prove not to be the vessel but the man
himself the unflappable Sir Ernest
Shackleton following a lengthy stopover
at a dank depressive destitute whaling
station at the end of the earth on South
Georgia island the crew were all too
eager to tackle their icy foe but
swiftly where their ambitions caught
short went Shackleton surprise they hit
almost a thousand miles of icy flows at
Vasil bay a steadfast earthy endurance
was its timber hull could not punch
through the impenetrable ice fortress
all too soon the crew were forced to cut
the ship's engines and stop over for 24
hours whilst the crew defiantly
endeavoured to decide what their next
move should be
after weeks of turbulent progress
through the gummy frigid ocean endurance
desisted an impassable glassier stood in
their way the waters quickly throws
around the hall forming an icy coffin
and on January 15 and Durin's ceased to
enjoy despite the entire crews
commendable efforts to free the vessel
through might man power and many
pickaxes the timber beasts could not be
stirred from its icy tomb Shackleton
soon conceded and announced that the
stranded endurance would become their
winter stopover until warmer weather
hopefully drew in Shackleton was
confident that progress could be resumed
once the icy hold asserted upon
endurance had dissolved to meltwater
such hope soon evaporated when it became
apparent to the crew that the
tremendously powerful glassy or place
surrounding endurance were slowly but
surely squeezing tightening and crushing
the vessel from all directions inwards
Shackleton feared that the ship would
soon implode under the unrelenting
pressure he was right yet despite the
fate of Shackleton and his men's home
station and only reasonable hope for
either progress or retreat being
consumed by the ice before their very
eyes
their morale never floundered in the
unimaginable conditions of the least
hospitable place on earth and under the
watch of many over a lesser captain the
crew could have easily fallen to
insanity hunger and illness but never
under his quiet resilience would
Shackleton's men be left so helpless by
their superior Shackleton sets his men
daily tasks such as finding and
preparing food he enforced recreations
such as regular games of football to
protect the men from poisoning their own
minds in October almost a year after
endurance departed from South Georgia
the men were finally given the order to
abandon ship no more than a month later
the ruthless sea had swallowed her whole
cleansing under the ice into the darkest
abyss the endurance have disappeared
Shackleton and his men made camp on a
small ice floe which they hoped would
drift toward Paulette Island
no less than 200 miles away where the
remainder of their cash had been stowed
Shackleton named this camp patience
count four days the men subsisted on
pitiful leftover supplies and scraps of
seal meat and blubber and most
regrettably of all I am sure following
the exhaustion of all of us sustenance
they shot and ate the 70 sled dogs the
ship's cat mrs. chippy was also
dispatched off for concerns that she
would only slow down the men and hinder
their survival chances the crews
carpenter Henri McNish was furious with
Shackleton's order to kill the cats The
Scotsman had grown rather fond of his
feline companion to their despair their
ice raft came within 60 miles of Paula
Thailand but they were unable to make
sure the despondent men were carried
past their last sacrilege of hope into
the endless never world of the cruel
ocean no longer masters of their own
fate now the winds the waves and wishful
thinking were their last bastions of
hope before long the ice floe began to
break it grew smaller by the day the
Shackleton ordered his men to board the
free remaining lifeboats and attempted
to sail north to Elephant Islands there
would be no much-needed food raffles to
meet them they're not even vegetation
nor animals but at least they could make
camp on solid ground for the first time
in 16 horrendous mores there is no
question that upon sighting Elephant
Island from their lifeboats the man
would have been overjoyed
despite its barren landscape
Shackleton's next move knowing that this
desolate Rock could not sustain them for
long would go down in the history books
as one of the most courageous daring and
perilous journeys ever attempted by man
leaving most of the crew on Elephant
Island Shackleton took the men aboard
one of the small wooden lifeboats on the
720 mile journey across some of the
roughest coldest and most hopeless
waters of our planet to reach South
Georgia island where their journey
originated from over a year ago just 17
days this gallant boat journey talk but
no doubts they were the 17 longest days
of these bold group of explorers had
ever known it is nothing short of a
miracle that their boat a microscopic
pinhead
upon the violence and Restless cushion
of the ocean was not flooded or capsized
starved empty skeletons of men barely
capable of lifting their arms to
navigate the small boat over 50
mile-per-hour gale force winds
obliterated both themselves and their
vessel when they did eventually hit
solid ground on South Georgia there was
not a whimper of jubilation between them
they collapsed instantly upon the beach
there was not a solemn grain of
consciousness remaining in their bodies
after some much-needed sleep Harry
McNish John Vincent and Timothy McAfee
were unable to carry on due to
exhaustion
so Shackleton Frank Worsley and Tom
Crean made what would be if only this
were a fairy tale one of the most
fantastical journeys history has known
once again within this tale of
never-ending hardship against all
worldly odds there wasn't a speck of
human life or salvation on this island
except for a whaling station on the
north side the freemen had landed on the
very southern tip standing between them
and rescue was 32 miles of a treacherous
and previously unexplored mountain
terrain
would put the most experienced Alpine
pioneers to the test
the scramble through the islands jacket
interior took 36 hours which considering
their disintegrated physical state and
complete lack of any climbing equipment
is rather astonishing they passed
through a frozen waterfall scrambled up
down and across undiscovered mountain
ranges and glasses not yet known to any
cartographer and at one point even rode
a makeshift sleigh down the side of a
mountain
upon reaching the Norwegian whaling
station the free man now no more than
tattered ghostly shells wearing torn
rags must have felt a gushing fountain
of relief rise up through their core
they knocked upon the door of mr. soul a
whaling station manager whose Shackleton
was well acquainted with and had spent
some time with years earlier during
their departure from the very same
station yet Saul did not recognize the
free weary shadows that stood before him
don't you know me
Shackleton pleaded I know your voice
my name is Shackleton come in come in
Sol responded in disbelief tell me when
was the war over Saul soberly responded
the war is not over millions are being
killed Europe is mad the world is mad
eventually they were welcomed warmly by
their Norwegian house and were sat down
for a hot meal and beverage but no
sooner had they eaten washed unshaved
did Shackleton's urgency turned towards
225 men across two camps who were still
on the brink of death awaiting his
rescue the next day Shackleton took a
borrowed whaling boat to the south of
South Georgia island to rescue the free
over men he had left there soon
afterwards the Chilean government lent
him a small ship to pick up the
expedition's remaining men
still camped out on Elephant Island
however it took for attempted voyages to
reach these men only during the
aforementioned fourth final voyage could
Shackleton actually reach Elephant
Island a testament to its remoteness and
inaccessibility Shackleton rescue of the
final encampment of men could not have
come a day later since his original
estimates which he gave to the men after
his initial departure had long passed
the men believed they had been forgotten
all Shackleton had perished discussions
of cannibalism disseminated through the
ranks discussions which were thankfully
cut short upon the merciful sight of
Shackleton's rescue craft heading like
an error of salvation directly towards
them not a single man died who was
aboard the endurance whilst on the
surface the Imperial Transantarctic
expedition may have been a failure sure
they fail to traverse the Antarctic
continent but I would say that the
endurance expedition was in truth one of
the most successful ever carried out
success in this case came from a group
of incredible men who defied death in no
small part due to Shackleton's unrivaled
ability to lead and most importantly to
be able to lift a comrade spirits in the
most ungodly circumstances that nature
could possibly and venom upon a man
Shackleton's placed within the annals of
historic legends is perhaps one of the
most deserved of all men thank you for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
I endeavor you to join the exclusive 42
members Club here on YouTube where you
can get early access to all my videos
and you'll occasionally get short
private vlogs from myself